- [Voiceover] Three L
minus six is greater than
or equal to eight.
Which of the following best
describes the solutions
to the inequality shown above?
So it's three times L
minus six is greater than
or equal to eight.
Well all of these choices,
these are in terms of L.
They've said L on one side is greater than
or equal to, actually all
of these choices are greater
than or equal to something else.
So let's see what we
can do to get just an L
on the left-hand side.
So the first thing we might want to do is
let's get rid of this subtracting the six,
and the best way we can do that is
we can add six.
Let's add six to both sides.
This six and this six
are going to add to zero,
and then we are going to be left with,
we are going to be left with
three L on the left hand side is
greater than or equal
to eight plus six is 14.
Now to just get an L on the left-hand side
we can divide both sides by three,
and if you divide both sides by three,
you're not going to change the sign,
you're not going to change the inequality.
If you're dividing by a negative number,
you would swap the inequality.
Greater than or equal to would turn
into less than or equal to,
but we're dividing by a positive number,
so this is going to be L is greater than
or equal to 14 over three
which is that choice right there.